-Well, we're at the point now
where the word "sedition"
and "heat ray" are in the news
at the same time.
Oh, and President Caligula
falsely blamed what he called
blue states for the coronavirus
death toll.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Been another week in our ongoing
John Carpenter hellscape,
you know, where The Thing
escaped from New York
only to move to DC to become
the prince of darkness,
and now there's big trouble in
little, well, everywhere.
Don't believe me?
The president lied repeatedly
about the timeline
for a COVID vaccine
and falsely blamed blue states
for the coronavirus death toll
while his Attorney General
suggested charging protesters
and political opponents,
including the mayor of Seattle,
with sedition, and compared
coronavirus lockdowns
to slavery.
The Justice Department looked
into filing charges
against officials in Portland,
and we found out that military
police had stockpiled ammunition
and a heat ray to use against
peaceful protesters
in the nation's capital.
-"The Washington Post" reports
a military whistleblower
says federal officials
stockpiled ammunition and sought
unusual crowd control devices
before clearing protesters
across the White House in June.
Defense officials asked
the DC National Guard
if it had a heat ray device.
The device makes people feel
like their skin is on fire.
-Just a reminder, we did
"A Closer Look" yesterday,
meaning this is all new [bleep]
This isn't a monthly catch-up.
You used to have to go in a coma
for this much to happen.
Now you just need to take a nap.
Things are so insane,
we're skipping past multiple
layers of news at once.
We don't have time to process
the fact
that the government
has a [bleep] heat ray
because we've already moved on
to the fact
that they considered using it
against peaceful protesters.
That's the same weapon
the Martians used
in "War of the Worlds."
Nothing is fiction anymore.
We should all start studying
the schematics of the Death Star
now just in case.
And while you're at it,
you know, study the schematics
for the second Death Star
from "Jedi" and then Starkiller
base from "Force Awakens,"
which let's be honest,
it's just a third Death Star.
Look, I know it's nine movies,
but you guys should probably
come up with some new weapons.
Huh, seems like their weaknesses
are the same.
I mean, I guess it's --
You know, it's bigger,
so that's something.
And if you don't believe me,
here's the president
talking about forest fires.
-In Europe,
they have forest cities.
You look at -- You look at
countries, Austria.
You look at so many countries.
They live in the forest.
They're considered forest
cities.
-Okay, so he's definitely
confusing Austria with Endor.
[ As Trump ] I talked to
the president of Austria,
and he told me something
I'll never forget.
He said to me, "Yub nub."
And you're hearing it
more and more.
[ Normal voice ] But I mean,
honestly, what's next?
A headline in
"The New York Times"
that says...
"The government
has a moon laser?"
"Yeah, man. Try to keep up."
"I took a nap."
"Yeah, well that's when
the [bleep] happens."
But as shocking as the news
about the heat ray is,
the truly disturbing thing here
is that our government
was stockpiling weapons,
including a heat ray.
Defense officials were searching
for crowd control technology
deemed too unpredictable
to use in war zones,
including the heat ray,
which uses millimeter wave
technology to essentially
heat the skin of people targeted
by its invisible ray
and makes anyone
within their range
feel like their skin is on fire.
Well, first of all, I've felt
like my skin is on fire
for almost four years.
So thank you,
President Heat Ray.
I mean, he does look like a guy
who when his mouth is closed
is working up a fireball
to launch.
And second,
this is so Bond villain.
If trump did have a heat ray,
he probably would have explained
his plan before he used it.
[ As Trump ]
It's a heat ray, James,
and once I use it on the crowd,
the rest of the plan is simple.
I will walk to a church
and wave a bible in the air.
[ As James Bond ]
But what's your end game, Trump?
[ As Trump ] Uh, I don't know.
Just to, like, look godly.
I don't know, really.
I don't think my plans through.
[ Normal voice ]
Think about how insane this is.
They wanted to use weapons
including a heat ray
against peaceful protesters
in America,
all so the president
could wave around a bible
in front of a church like
someone on a scavenger hunt.
"Guys, I found it.
Now all we need
is the signed head shot
of Steve Guttenberg,
and we're all done!"
This is what happened when
an unhinged political movement
talks about peaceful protesters
and political opponents
like they're enemies
of the state.
Trump and his allies in
right-wing media
have been using the language of
war to describe people
who challenge his authority.
As protests broke out
over the summer,
he called for
"overwhelming force"
and said you have to
"dominate the streets."
Just this weekend,
he used the word
"insurrection"
and called for retribution
in an interview on Fox News.
And he's repeatedly warned
that shadowy figures
are coming to destroy cities
and suburbs,
even making up psychotic lies
about anarchists
flying cross-country in planes.
-We had somebody get on a plane
from a certain city this weekend
and in the plane, it was almost
completely loaded with thugs
wearing these dark uniforms,
black uniforms with gear,
and this and that.
And there were like seven people
on the plane like this person.
Then a lot of people were on
the plane to do big damage.
The person was on a plane,
said there were about six people
like that person, more or less,
and what happened
is the entire plane filled up
with the looters,
the anarchists, the rioters,
people that obviously
were looking for trouble.
This was a firsthand account
of a plane
going from Washington
to wherever.
-I'm sorry. So your story
is a bunch of people were mad
at the government and wanted
to riot and loot
and so they went on kayak.com
the night before
and booked a flight away
from the nation's capitol,
somehow got six seats together,
then went to an airport
full of security cameras,
showed their IDs to several
people,
and quietly watched, what,
"Trolls" on their seatbacks
until they got to "wherever."?
That was a firsthand account
they were flying to "wherever"?
You might want to get
a second hand in there
to help with the details.
Trump would make such
a terrible witness
for a police sketch artist.
[ As Trump ]
Well, they had a head,
and beneath the head, there
was sort of a skin covered tube
that connected the head
to the shoulder area.
[ Normal voice ] "A neck"?
[ As Trump ]
Oh, so you know the guy?
[ Normal voice ] Also,
shadowy groups as a rule
don't give their operators
uniforms
and sit them together
on the plane in one big group.
You're thinking of Ashley's
bachelorette party.
We think we know
who the leader is.
She was wearing a tiara.
Besides, we all know
the only anarchists on flights
are the people
who crash the gate
before their boarding group
is called.
Those people are the real threat
to law and order.
-Hey, uh, better get up here
in case this is one of those
planes where 37-D
is up in the front.
No.
That happened a few weeks ago,
but the important thing here is
Trump was not alone
in spreading this insane rumor.
It appears to have originated
with a viral Facebook post
from a few months ago.
GOP congressman Devin Nunes
claimed he personally witnessed
the group of protesters
on a flight.
You remember ol' Nunes
over here, right?
The guy who always looks like
he didn't write anything down
during "Final Jeopardy!"
and then sues Alex Trebek
about it.
Then the head of Customs
and Border Protection
went on Fox News
and repeated the lie,
even though the agency
had to later admit
that there was no information
to support his claim.
In fact, last week,
a whistleblower accused
the Department
of Homeland Security
of distorting intelligence
to support Trump's lies
about Antifa.
And then last night we learned
in yet another bombshell story
that Trump's deranged
attorney general, Bill Barr,
suggested charging violent
protesters with sedition
and accused them of trying
to overthrow the government.
-Tonight, there are reports
the attorney general
has told federal Prosecutors
to consider charging
violent protesters
with conspiring
to overthrow our government.
"Wall Street Journal" was first
to report that Bill Barr
"encouraged the prosecutors
to seek a number
of federal charges,
including under
a rarely used sedition law."
-Man, things are bad, but I
never thought I'd hear the words
"sedition" and "heat ray"
in the same news cycle.
Our politics is now
half founding fathers,
half Power Rangers.
Bill Barr, you know, he's just
Trump with a law degree.
All you have to do
is imagine him with Trump hair
and circles around his eyes
standing next to some weirdo
B-list scam artist
like the demon-sperm doctor
or the MyPillow guy.
This is all --
This is all the culmination
of an increasingly unhinged and
abhorrent right-ring movement
that sees its political
opponents as illegitimate
and seeks to punish them.
That's why Trump
very obviously does not care
what happens to people living
in so-called blue states
during the coronavirus pandemic.
He basically said as much
yesterday.
-If you look at what we've done
and all the lives
that we've saved --
And I'm gonna ask
that a graph be put up.
And now it's up.
This was right at the beginning.
This was our prediction,
that if we do a really good job,
we'll be at about
100,000 to 240,000 deaths,
and we're below that
substantially,
and we'll see what comes out.
But that would be
if we did a good job.
And that's despite the fact
that the blue states
had tremendous death rates.
If you take the blue states out,
we're at a level
that I don't think anybody
in the world would be at.
We're really
at a very low level.
-Wow. Okay. So by that logic,
the more blue states we have,
the better the job you did
on this virus.
I think we're about to see
Fox anchors telling viewers
to help the President
by voting for Biden.
"Good news for President Trump,
as Florida has been called
for Joe Biden!
That's putting the blood
on his hands."
Also, as someone who lives
in one of those states
and knows people
affected by this virus,
I would just like to say
go [bleep] yourself,
you rotting
soulless business ham.
But, sure, if you just take out
all the people that died,
then you did a great job, dude.
By the same token,
if you take out all his albums,
Kid Rock has had
a fantastic career.
This has to be one
of the most grotesque things
the President has ever said.
I'm sure Trump's not
our first sociopath president,
but the he's definitely the
first one who's open about it.
He's the kid who lights ants
on fire for fun,
and when you catch him doing it,
he says,
"It's not what you think.
Torturing living things
gives me joy."
But it's also the most honest
articulation of Trump's beliefs.
If you can't empower
or enrich him personally,
he doesn't care about you.
It's the same ideology that
treats protesters as traitors
and calls for
political opponents
to be charged with sedition.
And, by the way, the only way
they can get away
with this stuff is because
we have an ass-backwards
electoral-college system
that lets Republican vampires
write off anyone
who doesn't live in one of
like a dozen swing states.
If we had a national
popular vote,
Trump and the GOP
would have to campaign in places
like Portland or New York City.
And I personally
would love to see him try
to pander to Portlanders
by growing a mustache
and riding a penny-farthing
to an artisanal pickle store.
"And this is --
this is a lot for a pickle.
You guys, this better be --
These are
pretty expensive pickles."
And this isn't the first --
"It's a good pic--
I'm just saying it's a lot --
it's a lot for a pickle."
This isn't the first time
Trump has made it clear
he doesn't care about Americans
who live in states
he didn't win.
Remember he also wanted to
cut federal aid to California
during the wildfires last year,
and a former
Homeland Security official
said Trump demanded
FEMA pull funding
because "California
didn't support him."
Just a few weeks ago,
he ordered federal agencies
to cut funding to what he called
anarchist jurisdictions
like New York, Seattle,
and Washington, D.C.
Trump only cares about the
health and safety of Americans
when it can help him
politically,
which is why, for example,
he's repeatedly claimed
a COVID vaccine
is right around the corner,
even though experts say
that's not true.
-We remain on track
to deliver a vaccine
before the end of the year and
maybe even before November 1st.
We think we can probably have it
sometime during
the month of October.
This could have taken
two or three years,
and instead it's going to be --
[ Chuckles ]
It's gonna be done
in a very short period of time.
Could even have it
during the month of October.
We're gonna have a vaccine in a
matter of -- a matter of weeks.
It could be four weeks.
It could be eight weeks.
-Could be four weeks.
Could be eight weeks.
He talks about
a life-saving vaccine
the way he probably talked
to the electrician
who wanted to get paid
for wiring Trump Tower.
"Mr. Trump, we sent you
the invoice months ago."
"And I'm gonna pay you, Tony.
Could be four weeks.
Could be eight weeks."
Also, experts have repeatedly
said it's highly unlikely
a vaccine could be available
by October.
I think Trump might be confusing
a coronavirus vaccine
with DQ's Pumpkin Pie Blizzard.
"We're very close, very close
to having -- having a vaccine.
The scientists are telling me
it will have, uh --
it will have real --
real pumpkin in it,
and, of course,
it will be topped
with, uh, whipped cream,
which, uh --
Dr. Fauci,
I believe you were saying --
would provide an extra layer
of protection against the virus.
He's covering his face.
That is scientist for 'yes.'"
Yesterday, the CDC director,
Dr. Robert Redfield,
went before Congress
and made clear
that even if a vaccine is
available for healthcare workers
and at-risk groups
by the end of the year,
it won't be broadly available
to the public at large
until summer or fall of 2021.
-I think there will be a vaccine
that initially will be available
sometime between
November and December.
But very limited supply
and will have to be prioritized.
If you're asking me when is it
going to be generally available
to the American public
so we can begin
to take advantage of vaccine
to get back to our regular life,
I think we're probably
looking at third --
late second quarter,
third quarter 2021.
-Oh, man, now I got to rescind
all those invitations I sent out
for a December celebratory
post-COVID orgy.
Still, you know,
it's probably better to do it
in the second or third quarter
next year.
You know, tax reasons.
Anyway, the point is, experts
agree a safe, effective vaccine
will very likely arrive,
and we have to be realistic
about the fact that things
aren't just going to instantly
revert to normal before then or
even after there's a vaccine.
We still need to practice
public-health measures
like hand-washing,
social distancing,
avoiding large crowds
and especially mask wearing.
We know universal mask wearing
can be extremely effective,
as Redfield made clear
in his testimony,
which is why it sucks
that we have a president
who says stuff like this.
-A lot of people
don't want to wear masks.
There are a lot of people who
think that masks are not good.
And there are a lot of people
that as an example --
-Who are those people?
-I'll tell you
who those people are.
Waiters. They come over,
and they serve you,
and they have a mask.
And I saw it the other day
where they were serving me.
And they're playing with a mask.
I'm not blaming them.
I'm just saying what happens.
They're playing with a mask,
and so the mask is over,
and they're touching it
and then
they're touching the plate.
That can't be good.
The concept of a mask is good,
but it also does --
You're constantly touching it.
You're touching your face.
You're touching plates.
There are people that
don't think masks are good.
-All right, first of all,
the only people who don't think
masks are good are ass [bleep]
who think they're standing up
for freedom by giving a teenager
a hard time at Costco.
"Don't tread on me...
Madison!"
Second, you think waiters
don't want to wear masks?
I'm pretty sure they would wear
masks even without a pandemic.
Then you wouldn't see
all their facial expressions
when people ask
for substitutions.
"Can I get the Greek salad,
feta on the side, add quinoa,
a tiny amount
of balsamic vinaigrette,
replace the cucumbers
with carrots,
and then switch them
back to cucumbers
and add the grilled chicken?
But instead of grilled,
can it be baked?
And instead of chicken,
can it be tofu,
but can you shape it
into a chicken?
Thank you, Madison."
What the President said
about discounting deaths
in so-called blue states was not
just another Trump gaffe.
It was an honest articulation
of his beliefs
and the beliefs
of the movement he leads.
The same goes for Barr,
comparing lockdowns to slavery
and wanting to charge people
with sedition.
It's an unhinged political
movement that sees anyone
who doesn't support them
as illegitimate
and wants
to dismantle democracy.
And if that happens,
we'll all have to move to Europe
to escape the Trump heat ray
and live with the Ewoks
in one of those...
-Forest cities.
-Yub nub, yub nub.
This has been A" Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, woman, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
Wear a mask. We love you.